en este vídeo quiero introducirte un
poco de terminología que será muy útil
en nuestra discusión de las funciones de
su invertibilidad y esta terminología
que seguro verás en cualquier carrera
relacionada con matemática es quizás
alguna ingeniería qué sé yo entonces
vamos a tomarnos primero como como hemos
estado haciéndolo una función que vaya
de un conjunto x a un conjunto y y
aunque ya hemos hecho bastantes de estos
dibujitos bueno nunca está además me
hace daño hacer otro de ellos entonces
digamos que aquí tengo mis dos conjuntos
este es el conjunto x este es el
conjunto y ax como ya sabemos le
llamamos el dominio y allí se le conoce
como el dominio verdad entonces nuestra
función f es una regleta que a cada
elemento de x le asigna un elemento de
verdad bajo la función f entonces vamos
a dar primero vamos a exhibir el primer
término qué
es la súper sub project y be that ok es
decir
efe es una función su project iba supra
directiva y que en algunas ocasiones
viene algunos libros también le pueden
llamar que es una función sobre depende
depende mucho el libro a mí me gusta más
usar su proyectiva y la idea de una
función su proyectiva es que
esencialmente todo este dominio y en
principio no todos los puntos de que
necesitan venir de alguien de x después
de aplicarle efe verdad es decir
nosotros podríamos tener aquí que a efe
le asigna distintos puntos pero podría
haber puntos en ye que no estén
asignados por nadie de x después de
aplicar la f sin embargo lo que dice una
función su proyectiva es que si ocurre
esto es decir que para cada y déjenme
hacerlo con otro color
y vamos a hacerlo con este
decimos que para cada para cada elemento
que se encuentre en nuestro dominio
existe y este es el simbolito de existe
verdad como una d mayúscula arriba al
revés existe al menos al menos se puede
haber varios pero al menos existe un x
que se encuentre en nuestro dominio tal
que tal que fx es igual a ye eso quiere
decir que no importa cuál llenos tomemos
por ejemplo este de aquí si una función
es su proyectiva va a existir alguien en
x de hecho podrían haber varios verdad
podrían haber varios que al aplicarles
la función f nos den el ok y quizás esto
se vea más fácil si nos tomamos un
conjunto más pequeño por ejemplo digamos
que el conjunto y es el conjunto de
letras a b
y de ok y este es nuestro conjunto y y
vamos a suponer que nuestro conjunto x
ok
este conjunto x es el conjunto de los
elementos 1 2 3 4 ok entonces si estos
por ejemplo asignamos una función efe
que al 1 lo manda a la a el 2 lo manda
al b el 3 lo manda al c y el 4 al de ok
esto es por supuesto aplicando cierta
función f
si nos damos cuenta no importa cual
letra nos tomemos en nuestro conjunto y
siempre va a haber alguien en nuestro
conjunto x que después de aplicarle la
función nos da ese elemento verdad por
ejemplo se podemos encontrar a este 3
que al aplicarle la función nos da c ok
entonces cuál sería un ejemplo de alguna
función que no fuera que no fuera su
proyectiva por ejemplo si agregamos una
letra verdad si agregamos una letra una
letra
entonces todos todos estos elementos si
quieren a alguien en x que después de
aplicarle efe se llegan a ese elemento
sin embargo la eno entonces basta con
que algunos de los elementos de nuestro
dominio no estén
no no se encuentren cómo se llama que no
sea la imagen de algún punto de nuestro
dominio basta con eso para que la
función no sea su proyectiva entonces en
nuestro primer caso si era su project
iba nuestro primer caso si era su
project iba ojo también le llamamos
sobre ok sin embargo ya en este segundo
caso en donde agregamos la e pues ya no
es su proyectiva verdad ya no es su
project iba y otra vez porque que quiere
decir que una función sea su project iba
que cualquier elemento en nuestro
dominio es la imagen de alguien en el
dominio aquí la e
pues no hay ningún elemento en nuestro
dominio que vaya a dar después de
aplicarla efe entonces realmente esta
última al considerar también el elemento
e no es su proyectiva sin embargo
también podríamos dar otra definición o
una definición más este sobre la su
project i be that por ejemplo si nos
consideramos
voy a elegir otro color más agradable si
nos tomamos una función efe su project
iba
consideremos una función la que ustedes
quieran su proyectiva o también sabemos
que es sobre
esto va a ser cierto si solo si ya hemos
discutido qué es esto decidí solo si la
imagen la imagen de nuestro de nuestra
función
efe es todo el condominio está
exactamente diciendo lo mismo verdad que
si nosotros nos en general la imagen es
todo el conjunto de puntos en el
condominio que son este que justamente
son la imagen de los puntos de x verdad
este esta imagen es todo el conjunto de
los fx donde x se encuentra en nuestro
dominio así que puede haber aquí puntos
fuera que no sean la imagen de nuestra
función es decir que no haya alguien en
x que vaya a dar bajo la función f a
este punto sin embargo si la función es
su proyectiva me está diciendo que la
imagen es todo el codo min yo es decir
que no hay puntos que no vengan de algún
elemento x después de aplicarle f verdad
y de hecho de hecho también en vez de
imagen le podemos llamar rango de verdad
es exactamente lo mismo de hecho vamos a
utilizar este término un poquito más a
veces en álgebra lineal a veces la
imagen pero bueno ok entonces la
diferencia esencial del co dominio y del
rango en en sí el rango está contenido
en el condominio pero no todo punto del
condominio tiene que ser la imagen de
algún punto de x entonces por eso es que
es distinto verdad ahora el siguiente
concepto que quiero discutir es el de
las funciones inyecte y bass ok entonces
tenemos una función función inyectaba
donde ojo a veces también le llaman una
función que es
que es de 11 a 1 y este nombre ya es
bastante sugerente dejen de hacer un
dibujito por ejemplo nuevamente tenemos
aquí nuestro conjunto x tenemos por acá
nuestro conjunto y ok y una función f en
general pues puede haber puntos puede
haber bueno tiene puntos ya que después
de aplicarles efe alguien alguien en x
llega a estos puntos pero bien podría
hacer que éstos no tengan una alguien en
x que al aplicarles efe y lleguen a este
conjunto que al aplicarles efe lleguen a
este elemento perdón es decir puede
haber para el caso de funciones inyecte
y bass no nos consideramos es el hecho
de que todos necesariamente tengan que
venir de alguien el el concepto de
inyecta vidad y aquí vamos a definir una
f inyectaba
no tiene tanto que ver con eso si no voy
a escribirlo para que quede más claro lo
que dice una función inyectaba es que no
puede haber dos elementos en x que vayan
a dar después de f al mismo punto en
jeff es decir que para cualquier
para cualquier que en nuestro conjunto
en nuestro condominio que se tiene que
algo más y voy a ponerlo con mayúsculas
a lo más existe existe bueno
voy a ponerlo así existe
1x en nuestro dominio tal que tal que fx
es igual ayer es decir el que sea lo más
le permite que a lo mejor haya puntos
que no tengan alguien que porque creo
que este punto no proviene de x después
de aplicar la f sin embargo hasta este
momento esta función que hemos pintado
si es inyectaba como no sería inyectaba
si a lo mejor aquí tenemos este punto va
a dar a este pero además este de aquí
que es distinto también va a dar a este
mismo punto entonces en este caso no
sería no sería una función inyectaba
porque estamos diciendo que algo más sea
un punto el que da aquí tenemos dos que
es mucho más de uno verdad no sería una
función inyectaba inyectó muy bien por
ejemplo si aquí agregamos un número más
y tuviéramos esta flecha de aquí
entonces esta función de aquí no es
inyectaba esta no es inyectaba porque
tenemos que el 4 y el 5 van a dar al
mismo un punto de tampoco eso proyectiva
entonces no tienen a veces relación a
alguna la inyecta vida deal a su project
i be that veremos en algunos casos en
donde sí pero bueno si a lo mejor
cambiáramos esta flecha está digamos la
quitamos y la ponemos de esta forma esta
final si es una función inyectaba y
también es su project y va